i know how to vacuum mom and dad summer
i've been doing it for six months but
why would you need to vacuum anything if
time is frozen
isn't everything frozen in time if the
molecules of the clothing are frozen how
do you even move them
how does the washer work now that i
think about it how are you even
breathing time frozen oxygen right now
it's not my fault we froze time on a
humid day but the moisture would
also free you know what let's just add
five cents for the paradox of freezing
time and move on shall we
you have dropped so many balls man i
mean
probably just two although with the
radiation rick has probably exposed
morty to with all the dimension hopping
could be more i suppose put a shirt on
your dumb dad and let's get this dumb
universe rolling
but how did morty get jerry's arms
through the sleeves sleeves just don't
magically form around the arms when you
throw a shirt on no matter how many
times you pray for it
when we pulled up i could have sworn the
house was completely trashed yeah well
everyone in the family knows that rick
can do incredible things so why don't
you immediately think
rick must have stopped time and fixed
the house before we walked in i'm just
gonna put it on the floor and uh kick it
on over to you nor you could toss jerry
the money so it doesn't look quite as
awkward i know jerry is supposed to be
dumb but beth isn't and she's a doctor
there's no way she's not checking
foreheads for tempter at the very least
asking questions about this odd behavior
whatever this is also convenient machine
that can let you know if there's been a
split in time on the off chance you
freeze time long enough for this to be a
possibility is convenient
the two of you made us uncertain what
are you talking about
exactly what does that mean uncertainty
is a pretty broad spectrum
for instance if morty was uncertain
about a math equation or if summer was
uncertain about what clothes she should
wear for that day would that cause a
time rift i get the rick as an ass when
it comes to explaining things but if
this issue of uncertainty is really that
important then maybe you should try a
little harder at least have a sheet with
rules on it
cold stone creamery is the best marble
slap creamery shaming
we we have to tell the cops you were
driving why would you have to tell the
cops anything or even call the cops do
you call the cops when you run over a
skunk or a squirrel i believe the saying
goes if the car will still steer
you're in the clear and we've got about
four hours to be
is what a very specific time frame you
just happened to know for convenient
engine building purposes
all right since this time crystal exists
in both possibilities and since it's
impossible that i didn't nail this
vanity it's definitely my favorite sin
naming your animal hospital animal
hospital do cars not need license plates
in this world
but how will people get in their
practice for removing tiny screws from
rusted out holes by using old credit
cards as an impromptu an ineffective
screwdriver
how i ask you nurse please move that
snake that's
my nurse indentured nursitude i shot it
before these two hit it with their car
and i followed them when they hauled it
off and how exactly were you able to
follow them
were you hunting from your car look the
scent is either convenient vehicle
location or car hunting take your pick
i'm calling my lawyer i hope for all our
sakes you're as bad a surgeon as i am a
hunter
this episode is an all-timer and
remembered mostly rightfully so for the
time rift storyline but it should also
be noted this b-story is equally
hilarious and engaging
all right everything resolved everybody
nice and certain about their position in
my world
yes i'm not sure i understand why morty
is so let down here just a couple
episodes ago he discovered that morty's
are a figurative shield for all rix
i'm not saying he should be happy that
rick looks down on him but he shouldn't
be surprised by it
this time be like grandpa you mean drunk
this is going to cause the ricks to go
out of sync and then both ricks are
going to take that as a sign that the
other rick is trying to kill him but
earlier morty said something different
from the other morty and then he said
wait who said that so wouldn't they have
heard the other morty making a wisecrack
about
rick and wouldn't rick know that it was
the reason for the sink to go out of
whack
think about getting in the coverage but
don't really but rick understands that
all of the ricks would be saying this
right the show has made rick really dumb
over the last 30 seconds for the sake of
moving the plot along
so for that away we go beth pushes jerry
with bloody gloves but there's no blood
transfer to his clothing and trust me
that stuff transfers
i mean so i hear i will reach into
heaven and make your screaming dear soul
back
the deer survives this well all of me
knocked out all the ricks and you peed
in all of your pants
doesn't that mean that we're all
synchronized i mean no
i haven't seen a timeline reverse
butterfly effect this hard since the red
green grumphold episode of the x-files
what are you doing
calling myself if leaving your other
selves a voicemail was an option this
entire time isn't that a pretty easy
immediate check before going full
interdimensional shooting gallery
how long exactly do we have to wear
these things they're really embarrassing
oh i see rick is an anti-massacre can we
talk about rick's cord maintenance for a
bit
he's got four plugs coming up from
behind the work counter and he chooses
to plug
three of them towards the top of the
first strip and one of them on the
upper strip and the one coming down from
the ceiling plugs into the
lower end of the top strip what is this
nonsense you have a cord
from below plugged in as your highest
cord you cord jumbling chaos monster
these men are from the servine institute
of elk moose deer and stag they can take
this deer to a helicopter
and fly it to the country's top deer
surgeon getting outsmarted by jerry
you know what they do to
third-dimensional life forms in time
prison same thing they do in every other
prison only forever
so three hots in a cot medical care
tobacco-based currency
oh you're making a prison rape joke
aren't you the last time we sent a
prison rape joke it was in puss in boots
so
you might want to think about the
company you keep r m i'm really
uncertain about everything
are you though certainly if the
uncertainty is a concerted plan you're
actually certain of your uncertainty
which would in turn create certain
certainty right
come on let's help grandpa yes i'm 100
not sure about anything at the war with
grandpa hand me that flat head
screwdriver
actually
so the decision over which screwdriver
rick should use split off the timelines
again
if something that minor would do it then
there should have already been hundreds
of these after rick was trying to figure
out which rick he needed to kill
there is no helicopter and there is no
cervin institute but clever ploy and all
but how did jerry get all the emblems
made so quickly to pull this off
and where did the uniforms the cold
stone creamery workers are wearing come
from
so the cats float but morty falls is
gravity itself
also uncertain well i guess they can
touch jerry and beth now without any
consequences but
how would they know that rick didn't let
them know how long they would have to
wait when they unfroze everything
are you going as motorcycles with green
headlights instead of normal ones i'm
not sure which i want to send more
that jerry would have this type 15 ready
to go right off the top of his head or
that beth who famously eye rolls just
about everything jerry does would be
laughing this hard at it
in fact i'm so uncertain there's now two
[Music]
cents
oh boy joe i i got to tell you that that
that sounds awful if you've ever wanted
to know what it's like to probe into the
back end of cinema sins and learn our
deepest darkest secrets behind the sins
podcast is just what you need each week
writers aaron that's me today
that's me and jonathan yep discuss what
it takes to create the content that you
enjoy on youtube
hopefully enjoy they probably do i mean
even if they don't we talk about it
that's true
i guess i'll just wrap this up real
quick and let you know that you can
listen to behind the scenes here on
youtube
or search for the show on your favorite
podcast player yep
are you okay yeah so what we'll do is
we'll rig a bus so that when it goes
below 50 miles an hour it blows up what
the [ __ ] is that
oh god now there's three of them there
too many of them what are we going to do
how misguided are you i feed you a
couple of bullsh
legal precedents and there you go you
jump on it like a [ __ ] and eat
how's it going bill and ted ted
it's us again so that's how it's gonna
be
y'all wanna play okay then
i've got my eye on you jquery that's
right mrs smith give
in to your anger let the heat flow
through you